thank you
right uh good evening members and
officers of council and members of the
press and public I welcome you to this
meeting of the council
so I shall go through as usual the
normal procedures if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices via
the stairs either through the security
doors to my right or opposite the lifts
in the foyer please do not use the lifts
please reassemble in holy Square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise winners it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber
I would advise that a filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have their image captured I
urge anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
I don't see anyone
any film you're recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion of
the press and public from the meeting
we have the usual restrictions on the
use of mobile phones with every everyone
present please ensure that their mobile
phones are turned silent and they are
not used to make or receive phone calls
whilst the meeting is in progress
good so on to agenda item number one
apologies from absent I have apologies
from counselors ARA Gregory and ference
do I have any other apologies for
absence
counselor Piper thank you Mr chairman
councilor John Dennis
and councilor Linda Potts
thank you councilor Piper any other
apologies
I don't see any other hands lifted
so agenda item 2 announcements I've not
actually been informed of any
announcements tonight but what I would
make clear is my birthday and so in
consequence I need to get home to my
birthday party and I just know that
we're going to have a straightforward
meeting this evening
councilor Everett
calm down calm down
well
that is that is charming and I did
wasn't after that yeah but yes
it could have done it could have done
chairman I'm sure the jelly will still
be there when you get home chairman well
I I I I look forward to that yes thanks
very much indeed anyway look so no other
announcements of any official nature uh
agenda item three Declarations of
Interest are there any Declarations of
Interest this evening
councilor Piper
thank you Mr chair first of all an
apology this hadn't dawned on me when we
had the pre-meet earlier this week
um and it I haven't filled in the form
uh point of clarification am I allowed
to do that
post this meeting but I have to declare
an interest I'm afraid on the budget
item because one of the items under the
fees and charges I was advised by our
legal department I was not allowed to
comment on or vote on or discuss
um and therefore given that that forms
part of the budget
presumably I will not be allowed to vote
on the budget so I will have to abstain
so my apologies to you I need to declare
the interest of my apologies to the
leader and also to counsel the Saunders
for the hard work that he and the team
are put in but my
decision to abstain is based on the
conflict of interest thank you Mr
chairman
well thank you very much indeed for that
councilor Piper you've made that very
plain I just wonder briefly if I might
turn to our legal officer for any
clarification
yeah that is correct chair Council will
need to declare an interest as you have
so you'll abstain from voting when it
comes to the voting party thank you
right well thank you for that councilor
Piper
agenda item four minutes of the previous
meeting
I move that the minutes of the meeting
of the council held on the 8th of
December 2022 be approved and signed as
a correct record
second that chair two members agree
foreign
the treasury management strategy and
annual investment strategy for 2023 2024
it's your night councilor Saunders
I certainly am we're all looking forward
to it
then I shall stand
chairman this is a generalizing five
treasury management this report is
required in accordance with the CIP fa
code of practice on Treasury management
it covers our Capital spending and
financing plans and its treasury
strategy backed by Prudential indicators
and limits
the report also presents for approval
the council's minimum Revenue provision
policy Capital strategy investment
strategy and non-treasury Investments
report for the next financial year
A draft copy of this report was
considered by the governance and audit
committee on the 30th of November 2022
seems a long while ago now doesn't it
and by the cabinet on the 12th of
January 2023
chairman I move the recommendations
within the report thank you
thank you councilor Saunders do you have
a secondary
councilor Ashby
counselor Yates
thank you chair
um thank you for the report Council
Saunders given the council's long-term
borrowing short-term Investments and
internal borrowing we thank our finance
Finance officers for their prudent
approach on the public purse
that's it thanks
thank you very much indeed Council Yates
do members agree
thank you very much indeed gender item
three
the HRA budget for 2023 2024
so yes item six it certainly is
there you are me jumping the gun
very observant this evening aren't you
all
now then I would advise that in
accordance with Council procedure rule
17.6 I will call for a recorded vote on
the motion or any Amendments of
subtantive motions
I call once again on councilor David
Saunders
thank you chairman I will move on to
agenda item six I prefer to go back to
free but I'll carry on with the gender
item six which is the HRA budget next
year's HRA budget is underpinned by a
seven percent increase in rent which is
in line with the minimum of the maximum
cap set nationally by the government
this equates to an average rental
increase of six pounds 20 pence per week
for our tenants the majority of which
and that's approximately 75 percent will
be covered by increased housing benefit
or Universal Credit payments to our
tenants the HRI has been running at a
deficit for a number of years partly due
to the imposition of statutory rental
reductions and then caps being placed on
rent increases in recent years
I enjoyed that noise the deficit has
been put under further strain this year
due to the high inflation environment
and the consequent increase in the
council's costs as such this level of
proposed rent increase is needed to
continue to drive the HRA to a balanced
and sustainable financial position and
also to finance our ambitious affordable
house building program and housing
investment plan chairman I move the
recommendations within the report thank
you
thank you very much councilor Saunders
do you have a second uh councilor Ashby
to councilor Whitehead you've indicated
thank you chair and happy birthday
we are being asked today to approve an
average rent increase for our tenants of
six pound twenty per week or 322 pounds
40 per year
our strategic priorities aim to maintain
a rent and charging policy that is both
affordable for residents and ensures the
resources needed for investment in homes
and services
for many of our residents no increase is
Affordable but we are also required to
fulfill the last part of this priority
to ensure their resource is needed for
investment in homes and services
without adequate Central investment both
parts of this priority are in direct
conflict with each other regardless of
the best intentions of all offices and
councilors involved
the best we can often do is continue to
protect those who are most vulnerable
in Labor's last budget that is exactly
what I did
in 2020 I propose an average increase of
83 Pence per week in order to maintain
our portfolio and reduce our housing
list I did so only after deliberately
excluding residents on affordable rent
from that rise as they were most likely
to not have the rent increase covered by
housing benefit
at that point the conservative group
refused to support our budget citing
this 83 Pence increase in rent even
though this was an increase that
deliberately excluded costs towards
those whose increase would not be
covered wholly by benefits
today we are being asked to approve an
increase of six pound twenty per week or
322 pounds 40 per year at a time when
there are extraordinary Financial
pressures on residents
we are asked to note that roughly three
quarters or 75 percent of our tenants
are accessing benefits which can reduce
the impact of this rise conversely that
means that one in four will be affected
by it
on 12th of January I asked cabinet to
exclude tenants on affordable rent from
this increase as I did in 2020.
today I again asked cabinet to consider
the impact this will have on those who
are already facing hardship
I know that these decisions are
difficult because I have taken them I
know that it is often an impossible
equation to balance because I have tried
but I've always tried to protect those
who need it and being asked to approve a
seven-fold increase that does not
provide that protection when I face
censure in the rejection of an entire
budget based on an 83 Pence increase
that did protect the most vulnerable I'm
left considering two things
firstly the impact that this increase
will have regardless of intent and
secondly that for any counselor who
refused to support the 2020 budget based
on 83 Pence increase a raised hand
tonight is a public acknowledgment that
refusing to support that budget was
simply a game to avoid supporting labor
I will play No Such games because all of
us need to be better than that we
support each other in finding the right
decisions and we build public faith in
politics in doing so I ask instead that
we simply look at the gravity of what we
are being asked to agree and explore
what discussions have been had around my
proposal thank you
thank you very much indeed for that
councilor Whitehead do I have any other
speakers
councilor councilor um bayford sorry
from paying rents that are substantial
on the market rate
those who are financially vulnerable
will not pay the increases it will be
covered by the benefits they receive
we feel it is crucial that the HRA moves
out of deficit particularly so that the
health housing are able to carry out
their ambitious building program in
order to help meet the increasing needs
of our residents which I think is
understood by all
our tenant and leaseholder group have
approved the increases but requests that
when tenants are informed of this an
explanation of how the rent money is
spent is included we have agreed to this
request thank you
okay thank you councilor Beaufort uh any
other speakers
and I don't see anybody I shall ask the
interim head of legal and monitoring
officer services to conduct a recorded
vote
thank you chair
members you're voting for recommendation
either for against or abstention
I'll call the names in alphabetical
order so if you just indicate for or
against
cancer Alban against
chair sorry can I
sorry I didn't see you
so
sorry um are we clear it was councilor
Whitehead proposing an amendment or she
wasn't okay no I didn't can we just
clarify what we're actually working on
here I thought I thought and councilor
Whitehead was giving an explanation of
her position with respect to this item
and she was not proposing so far I'm
aware an amendment
no as I'd already asked cabinet to
consider it um I was simply asking for
feedback on what had been discussed and
considered thank you
thank you chair just so seeking that we
are voting to um agree the HRA budget as
written thank you
are we clear what we're agreed on it's
the recommendation
for the HRA budget right let's start
again
Casa open
in in part of the clarification I vote
for chair thank you
councilor Ashby
for
counselor Austin
councilor Bailey for
councilor bembridge
councilor Jill bayford
Council Robert bayford or councilor Boyd
councilor breakwood
for
counselor Coleman cook
foreign
councilor Curry
Council Dexter
councilor Duckworth councilor Everett
councilor fellas
Council Garner
councilor Hart
councilor Hopkinson
councilor Huxley
councilor Keane
councilor cup
Council lace
councilor Pat Moore
councilor Pomo
Casa Marie Anne-Marie nixley
Nixie
Nixie sorry
for apologies councilor ovenden
councilor Parson
councilinda Piper
councilor Stuart Piper
councilor pug
cancer
both
that's a roof
for
Council Rogers
no Castle watches
for
Dr rosinsky
Caster David saunderson Saunders for
counselor May Saunders
councilor Savage for Council scoby
Caster Scott Castle
counselor Smith
counselor Tomlinson
cancer toning
councilor rolling
Castle Whitehead
and consideration of the tenant and
leaseholder group for
counselor
counselor Wright
counselor Yates for that's unanimous
that was any unanimous member says I'm
sure you realize
so I press on to a gender item seven
budget for the
2023-2024 a medium-term financial
strategy
2022-2026 five yeah six
uh I would advise that in accordance
with Council procedure rule 70.6 I will
call again for a recorded vote on the
motion or any Amendment and substantive
motions
um I therefore call once again on
councilor David Saunders
thank you chairman and I guess this is
the main event this evening
I'm very pleased to be able to present a
balanced budget for 23.24 to the council
this evening the budget setting process
began in the summer of 2022 and cabinet
and officers have dedicated a tremendous
amount of time and effort to get to the
position we are now in
that is with a balanced budget my thanks
go to all who have been involved and
contributed to this process and I have
to say that the financial team has given
myself superb support and
um that goes for all of the
um budget holders that attended all of
the Star chambers that we held all 19 of
them in order to come up with this
budget this balance budget despite what
may seem like a lengthy and complicated
process and believe you me it was this
level of planning is of critical
importance it's how we continue to
deliver the services that matter to the
people and protect and support our most
vulnerable residents this report sets
out the cabinet's recommendations to
council for next year's budget we are
recommending to increase our net
spending on local Services by 3.5
million pounds or 19.6 for the budget
year
it is accepted that this is a
significant increase but the district
council faces the same cost increases as
everyone else on fuel transport and pay
and this has to be funded I'm afraid
inflation is at 40 at a 40-year higher
and the current economic climate makes
it difficult to predict the future
and I wouldn't like to second guess what
the future holds for us
in addition to the increased cost of
delivering Services The Wider difficult
economic climate means that demand for
some of our key Services most notably
temporary accommodation for the homeless
people is rising providing a safety net
for people who have nowhere to live is
one of the most important things that we
do but it is demand driven and costs I'm
afraid of rising
I'm also proud to be presenting a number
of proposals to invest in some of the
council's key Services which make a
difference to our local people
with more spending on priorities such as
an improved CCTV system the recruitment
of five Coastal enforcement officers and
more money for seaweed collection and
Coastal cleansing
despite the fact that inflation is
running at around 10 percent our core
funding has only increased by 5.8
percent and the council is only allowed
to increase council tax by a maximum of
three percent
therefore we look to maximize our local
income so that we can improve and
provide quality services for local
people
we're doing this by maximizing key
income streams by changing Services
which are only used by a limited
proportion of the residents it is
important the council organizes itself
in ways that maximize that income for
investment in Services whilst balancing
this with managing the input
of our residents and service universe
as such our strategy has been to apply a
broad 10 increase to fees and charges
where possible and it's not always been
possible
which is expected to generate additional
income of six hundred and ten thousand
pounds for next year's budget the
proposed fees and charges are set out in
Annex one to this report
however before we enter into debate I
need to draw a members attention to an
error regarding charges for the water
users
[Applause]
the proposed fees for annual membership
for the water users group is listed on
page 144 of the agenda as a hundred and
fifty pounds however this figure is in
error with a 10 increase on last year's
fees this would be approximately 80
pounds but in order to fund the rollout
of replacement locks and keys improved
signage and also improve the swim Zone
marker boys the fee is proposed to be
set at 110 pounds for the year 20
2023-24 this is still less than the fee
charged that other UK managed slipways I
have to say or Untold
this correction does not have a material
impact on the anticipated income budgets
for the fourth coming year
I trust that members will be in
agreement with this amendment alongside
the overall schedule of fees and charges
as well as consideration by cabinet and
officers the proposed schedule of fees
and charges was carefully reviewed by
the cross-party cabinet Advisory Group
and also was considered by the overview
and scrutiny panel at its meeting on the
17th of January 2023
in addition to optimizing our fees and
charges we're also planning to invest
more in the council's property portfolio
with the clear objective to increase
income and Council earns to increase the
income that Council earns from its
property assets
moving on to the capital program the
council has substantial investment
program to deliver over the next four
years through ongoing leveling up fund
projects for both Margate and Ramsgate
and also the Margate Town deal These
funds provide the opportunity for
significant investment in two of The
District's towns and the impacts on the
budget are set out in the draft Capital
programs for 23 to 27.
finally the proposed increase in council
tax at seven pounds 42 per band D
equivalent property represents an
increase of less than 15 Pence a week
for each household within that band
chairman
I've never read so much for a long long
while
I move the recommendations within the
Ripple thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
Saunders do you have a second for that
councilor Ashby
thank you chair and uh thank you to
councilor Saunders labor would like to
thank the council's finance team and the
council officers for their hard work on
this year's budget this budget is being
set with a backdrop of a serious cost of
living crisis the climate emergency is
constantly on our minds and residents
have a concerns about what's happening
in thanet
labor does have proposals that can
address these concerns which we'll go on
to so I'd like to thank you for your
patience tonight I'll start with a brief
response to the budget and Labor's First
Amendment
to begin with I would like to welcome
our new chief executive to his new role
he isn't here tonight we would welcome
his interim leadership during this time
there have also been other changes since
last year's budget
we had Boris Johnson who was removed by
his colleagues in September who had Liz
truss for the whole of 50 days
who resigned after crushing the markets
and now Rishi who has been in over 100
yet days but that won't last long
even with so many prime ministers some
things do not seem to change local
governments are still not getting the
funding that they need
thanet has the second highest number of
homes in Kent he had the second lowest
funding from council tax
we need to stop drip feeding local
government and we need better funding
mechanisms
so onto the budget broadly speaking
labor thinks this budget is a positive
step for thanet although we do think
more can be done it is positive that we
are planning to use the property repair
and maintenance Reserve I'm confident
the members across the room will have an
idea on how they should be spent but one
item that jumps out for me is to ensure
the remaining boiler and Winter Gardens
is kept going
the additional CCC CCTV operatives is
one we fully support and aligns with our
resident survey where 51 of residents
said their top priority is making thanet
in in making than a good place to live
was feeling safe
the addition of a new climate change
coordinator role is great news and one
we fully support and additional Economic
Development officer role is welcomed we
welcome the investment into our future
vehicle and Equipment replacement
program and it's great to see the
council confirm that in writing the plan
to Electrify the refuse collection
Vehicles by 2030.
spending 2.2 million for the further
provision of temporary homeless
accommodation is necessary and the right
thing to do though it does highlight the
housing market failure we see nationally
and we welcome the Innovative idea to
put 415 000 pounds of new homes bonus
money to part finance a capital scheme
for homelessness accommodation it does
sound rather familiar though I believe
it is exactly what the labor group
proposed at the last budget and yet it
was voted down
already labor has proposed one Amendment
to the council's budget which is
introducing a home energy cold Buster
officer
this is now being brought to the March
cabinet meeting and I believe councilor
Saunders when he says that he'll take
this option seriously when when it comes
to Cabinet next month
so on fees and charges labor made clear
at fees and charges
um that we the fees and charged working
group that we wanted additional support
for our residents
this this recommendation was ignored and
instead this Administration seems to be
stubbornly demanding we charge a
residents 10 more each year to park
outside their homes and in our car parks
the Times newspaper spotted that 10
increase of parking with the newspaper
article quoting the heads of Road policy
at the a saying residents could soon
vote with their wheels and decide to
avoid Town centers and shop online
but it will not only affect our
businesses it will also mean the planet
resident with an annual Car Park season
ticket will need an additional 64 pounds
more than last year in order to go about
their daily life so on to our first
amendment and I think that gives me an
additional three minutes
right yes I just simply mentioned that
your Amendment ends on a semicolon so am
I missing something
um it should be a full stop please
excuse my uh
my inaccuracy on that
is that acceptable can I carry on yes I
believe so do carry on here thank you
so I'll start with the First Amendment
remove the planned increase in charges
for residents and visitor permits and
this is car parking resulting in charges
being frozen are there 20 20 to 23 level
with a corresponding reduction in
forecast income managed through the
council's earmarked reserve for
on-street parking
so this if you're interested in the fees
and charges can be found at the bottom
of page 8 on the spreadsheet on the top
of page nine under residence parking
permits and the title residence parking
areas
our fees and charges we made clear we
need to protect residents from whopping
parking increases we have been
consistent by requesting that we remove
the increase to resident and visitor
permits for our residents we do not
believe that this will have an impact on
traffic management but it will have an
impact on a bigger issue ensuring our
residents have more money in their
pockets thank you I move the motion
Amendment
thank you very much new councilor Yates
uh councilor Everett were you seconding
you did want to speak didn't you
thank you chair um I will second the
amendment and I'd like to speak to it if
that's all right
um I'm on the record as saying that um I
was unhappy about the 10 increase in
parking charges for this Council
um and I feel therefore the council
deserves some explanation as to why I'm
not proposing a wider reduction this
evening
um and the reason is that we have
explored this issue
um ad nauseam with the 151 officer and
he's been very helpful in explaining the
legalities around it and we're revised
that if we were to recommend a change
from 10 we would potentially open to
question whether the council was setting
its parking charges
um in line with the requirements of
traffic management
now this seems to me to be a very
unsatisfactory State of Affairs because
it is for Council to set the parking
charges it's not the cabinet it's not
for officers nevertheless that's where
we are and I think the responsible thing
for the labor groups tonight is to take
the advice of the 151 officer on that
matter and not bring the council into
potential conflict with the district's
auditor so I'm unable to propose an
amendment which reduces the 10 increase
across the board and but I fully support
what council the Yates has proposed it
is a small gesture to those of our
residents who have to pay to park uh in
their local area and to the positions
who they have it is focused on our
residents it's not focused on people
from outside the district and I hope
that the council will support this
modest and sensible Amendment thank you
thank you councilor ever would anyone
else like to speak on that Amendment
councilor Saunders
thank you chairman I'd like to respond
um
well it's come out of the blue
um but then I suppose I'm looking around
Paul robeson's not here so I accept
there's going to be a little bit of
showboating this evening
um I'm unaware of the impact on this on
our fees and charges and also the impact
on our earmarked reserves so I can't
comment what I will say is that yes I
have
made it quite clear that I wish and
we've only got a very short time but
I've put a lot of input into the new
parking strategy and I've made it
absolutely clear that whatever comes out
of the new parking strategy and I'm
afraid I won't be here to see it come to
fruition it needs to be
um on the side of our residence and
Resident parking and the permits are
part of that strategy I want to get to a
situation where our residents are not
penalized for parking
um that they are subsidized by visitors
to the area and we're working on the
strategy we believe that we had a for
scheme we've included additional CCTV
cameras which are all part of our future
plans for coming up with a parking
strategy that is fair to our residents
and gives them the benefit of yes being
able to park outside their house and
with a resident parking permits I'd like
to get to a situation where they could
actually park outside of their house if
their houses are in the parking zones
rather than have the opportunity of
parking there if a space is available or
driving around and finding a space
within their Zone and if not having the
pay they that is totally wrong I agree
with everything said but I really can't
accept this amendment until I know
exactly what the cost implications are
thank you chairman
thank you very much indeed cancer
Saunders councilor Yates you have a
point of order I was just wondering
whether the section 151 officer might be
able to confirm what I believe is is
that it's an it's a reduction in fees
and charges of six thousand pounds
I can answer section 151 officer if he
would like to comment or able to comment
to this point
thank you chair yes so on street parking
operates through a slightly different
arrangement to off street parking so any
income that we cut from on Street goes
through an earmark Reserve that is
reserved just for those purposes we
collect about 50 000 pounds a year from
residence permit and 14 000 from
visitors permits
so by freezing them we'd we'd forego
about uh six thousand pounds in
additional income that would be
allocated to the decrim reserve this is
a manageable amount considered the
overall sums of money that are allocated
to the decrim reserve from overall on
street car parking if members wish to
consider it
thank you very much indeed for that
um any other speakers to the amendment
councilor Saunders you're back chairman
thank you uh Chris 151 officer
um as we're only speaking about a
comparatively small amount I'm quite
happy to accept this amendment
it would have been nice to know in
advance we could have saved this
grandstanding
well yes
um
notwithstanding nevertheless it would
seem that um this is meeting with some
approval are there any other speakers on
this amendment
I'm hoping
councilor Austin yes sorry thank you
um I just wanted to pick up on councilor
Saunders comments sorry I want to come
pick up and cancel Saunders comments
about the parking review because we did
ask for various changes during at the
fees and charges CAG and I think it came
up again overview in scrutiny and we
were told the parking review wasn't
happening yet it's not happening it's
not happening everything will have to
wait for that but from what councilor
Saunders is saying now it sounded like
it was underway and it would be useful
to know where we're at with that and
what stakeholder engagement we're doing
Etc
um because obviously that feeds into
this discussion thank you
thank you very much indeed for that
councilor Saunders would you are you
able to respond to that
I'm indeed
um it's not actually underway
um the lead officer has confirmed to me
and it's it's been put in writing that
we're expecting
um it in June
um it's definitely underway and the last
information that I had was that the we
are now in a position to actually go out
to procurement once that's done and once
we make a decision on who we want to
manage this and prepare the report for
us then we will go to the various
stakeholders I've made that absolutely
clear that everyone needs to have an
input because it's
an even more difficult subject than this
budget quite honestly but it's important
that we get it through because it will
include a provision for electric
vehicles Etc so it's it's it's important
on many many fronts thank you
thank you councilor Saunders you're
you're on the ball aren't you there any
other speakers to the amendment
don't see anybody else
anyway
now even as an amendment we need to vote
for this is a recorded vote so once
again our call on the monitoring officer
thank you chair
again I'll start with the in the
alphabetical order and you're waiting
for or against or abstention counts are
open
councilor Ashby for
counselor Austin
councilor Bailey for counselor Ben
Bridge
councilor Jill bayford
councilor Robert bayford
councilor Boyd
counselor Brightwood
Castle Coleman cook
Castle Crittenden
Castle Curry
councilor Dexter
councilor Duckworth councilor Everett
councilor fellows
Council Garner
councilor Hart
councilor Hopkinson
councilor Huxley
counselor Keane councilor cup
counselor lace
counselor Pat Moore
councilor Pomo
councilor Anne-Marie Nixie
counselor ovenden
councilor Paulson
Council Linda Piper
counselor Stuart Piper you
abstaining thank you
counselor Pugh apologies for pronouncing
your name incorrectly earlier
I would I would just like to put on the
record chair that's not the worst
attempt to my surname that I have ever
heard I'm not going to give members the
other examples but thank you Samira I am
I'm for this
it's the first time I was doing Easter
apologies
any so it was could you confirm your
vote for
uh Council ratigan Council Grove
Council of Rogers
inski
councilor David Saunders for councilor
Dave Saunders councilor Savage for
Caster scoby Council Scott
counselor chunk
yeah counselor shop counselor Smith
Tomlinson Council towning Council of
Walling
Castle Whitehead
Castle wing
this thing
counselor right
and finally Council Yates
okay
yes thank you very much indeed that's
agreed uh we return to the substantive
motion
I have councilor Auburn
so I'd like to make an amendment chair
please
thank you
um I could assure couns as soon as I've
got no cane no no hat to wear so I won't
be showboating chair uh
this is an important item and uh I have
no wish to do that at all
so the amendment I'm proposing is as
follows
remove 85 000 pound growth from the
Estates budget for ongoing Staffing
Resources
to be replaced by a hundred and seventy
thousand pound allocation
from the risk Reserve to provide
Temporary Staffing Resources in the
estate's budget over two years
the 85
000 pounds saved been allocated to the
street cleansing budget to provide
additional resources for the creation of
three full-time equivalent environmental
operative roles within the base budget
and I do this chair by saying that the
second most important thing that our
residents have told us in the Resident
survey
is they want cleaner streets chair
and by providing at least three that we
can get out of this budget in a safe and
good way
um that will show that this council is
actually listening to our residents and
I would whilst I have no way of telling
our officers how these should be used
but I would say chair that they should
be within the residential areas and that
and that our residents can actually see
that we're listing and that's taking
place
I so move chair thank you thank you
councilor Auburn I take that Amendment
do you have a second to counselor
Everett do you wish to speak yes
yes this amendment is designed to focus
the budget more closely on the
priorities of our residents and I don't
think there can be any member of this
Council who's not aware that one of the
biggest priorities of our residences
litter on our streets it is the single
biggest issue that you ever encounter on
the doorstep and quite honestly it's the
single biggest issue you encounter as
you walk around than it and I think this
modest proposal and it is a modest
proposal
can do nothing
detrimental in terms of that issue we
are very keen to support the expansion
of the estate's budget and we would not
wish to do anything which made it more
difficult for Estates to bring in more
income for the council which I know is
the purpose of the growth in the budget
proposal and I just want to read to you
with his permission what the 151 officer
said about this proposal and clearly
he's not expressing an opinion about
whether he's in favor of it or not but
he did say the reallocation of resources
here is a sensible and financially
feasible proposal
that being the case members we have an
opportunity to show our residents that
we understand their main concern is
street cleaning and I think the
opportunity will be missed if we focus
on back office development at the
expense of street cleaning we can have
both and we will get it if we vote for
this amendment thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
Everett and that's proposed and seconded
do I have any other speakers
we've got councilor bayford
yeah thank you chairman
um thank you councilor Auburn I agree
with you absolutely and clean streets
are a great priority and this
Administration takes that very seriously
and to that end I can tell Council that
we're currently undertaking review of
cleansing Services what we believe is
that we can improve the service without
extra budget that's what we hope to do
so we're looking at changing the work
patterns for people we're looking to
trial electric behind vehicles and
something that
that's the lovely name of the vacuum
glutton I'm told that if we actually do
find these trousers successful and
actually go for this Machinery it will
make a huge impact on the cleanliness of
our streets so I personally think that
it's better that we try and improve the
service within the budget that we've got
thank you thank you councilor Beaver
councilor Ashby
um
mine takes me takes me to a Time
in it and there was an introduction of I
believe 10 street cleaning operatives
unfortunately the labor administration
at that time didn't manage to actually
fill those roles and when we resume
control of the council the following
year we did maintain those positions
within it so
um
the whole point of the um
the Estates team and
um
the reason for that we put the amount in
there to grow this team not taking our
reserves but to take it out from the
general fund is the fact that we need as
a council to
earn our way to earn our living and if
we get this right and with this proposal
in this platform then we will be able to
go forward on a sustainable basis and be
able to recruit year on year more
allocation to the various resources that
we need to provide the services to the
to the residents that we
we fall short on in some of the areas
but I do feel that this actually is the
right way forward and I'm afraid that I
cannot support
your proposal in this case thank you
chair
thank you very much indeed councilor
Ashby and I think I've got an indication
yes councilor Wing I've temporarily
forgot your name sorry thank you chair
you've got a birthday coming so
you're otherwise distracted I'm
conflicted I mean it would have been
nice for us to have been aware of this
motion beforehand because I represent
award you know and had more discussion
about the implications of it I sit in a
world that desperately wants its Market
back you know and that's a high a high
need within within my world Central
Harbor and that issue sits within the
Estates team but I'm also personally and
as a world counselor really concerned
about the rubbish and litter on our
seats so much so that I'm often out
picking the litter up so I I find I'm
conflicted I want to support the motion
but I also don't want to see the Estates
team impacted and perhaps we have to
wait even longer for our Market to
return because the Estates team quite
clearly too much to do and not enough
people so is there any indication that
anybody can give me about the loss of
that finance that the Estates team and
what it means there
thank you very much indeed counselor
Wing I mean
at this point yes I suppose are you able
to give some clarification
one by one I'm happy to but I'm equally
I can see that uh Council Yates is happy
to respond on this so
councilor Yates um what I would mention
just briefly everyone is that I'm still
recovering from an operation on my right
eye
so seriously if I don't see you uh bear
with me counselor Yates thank you chair
um just speaking to the financing of
this so this will be Finance
um instead of from the general fund
budget it'll be funded it'll be financed
in my reserves so we'll be using our
reserves to fund these three posts
um to fund the Estates team sorry
um so we're not there's no reduction in
Staffing it's just coming from reserves
rather than coming from the general fund
budget thank you
we have a further clarification from the
151 officer I just um wanted to add a
little bit more context in terms of the
advice provided here when looking at
using our reserves it's typically that
we would use these for temporary funding
which is why this is a feasible thing to
do because these are time limited posts
that we're looking at within the Estates
team we wouldn't want to be using
reserves so for an ongoing pressure so
usually when we're looking at setting
the budgets we don't want to use
reserves on an ongoing basis because you
can only be using them once however
there's a significant backlog in the
Estates team and we think that some of
those resources are only needed for a
Time limited period of time until that
backlog is cleared so it is feasible to
use the reserves for that two-year
period
to address that situation and switch the
funding that was going to be put into
the base budget instead and allocate
that to Street cleansing that is a as a
feasible uh and sustainable budget
amendment if members wish to consider it
thank you for that clarification to
Castle Roth did you indicate you did
yes thank you chair well I agree growth
is a big part of any Financial in any
stage but I think the street cleaning is
a much important thing to the resident
of thanet anyone you speak to they say
are paid tax why my rubbish simple
things you cannot take my rubbish away
what council can do what you cannot
clean outside my house you cannot clean
the street I think I support this
amendment because that is what residents
pay for and that's what resident would
thank you
thank you thank you councilor Ralphie
there are no more speakers can we our
councilor Saunders did you want to come
back in
well as she's invited me I didn't put my
hand up
um
obviously obviously again I would have
liked to have had this uh before me
um before this meeting and the advice
that we've received from the 151 officer
what I would say is that as members know
um I am frequently contacted with
regards to local organizations and our
tenants with regards to rent reviews uh
leases etc etc and our plans that we've
been discussing at the star Chambers
would mean that the resource would be
put into the Estates department so that
we can tackle this issue and this issue
is
um
fundamental to our Revenue stream I
accept what's being told and what's
being said
and I just wonder if I was to agree to
this amendment when would these street
cleaners start because I do know that
we've got people for the Estates
Department sitting on the standing
blocks as we speak this evening and I'm
not aware that we've got people who want
to come sweep our streets immediately
available it's something that can be
looked at in the future but on as far as
this budget is concerned I cannot
support this amendment thank you
thank you very much Nick House of
Saunders back to you councilor Alban yes
thank you chair just to just to make one
point of clarification share
um obviously this budget doesn't start
until after April
thank you
thank you councilor Auburn just before
we move to the vote councilor Whitehead
thank you chair
um just for clarity but for my own also
um I'm pretty certain that what's being
proposed isn't an either or option it's
simply a movement of finances to enable
both
correct thank you thank you very much
can I move some monitoring officer for a
recorded vote councilor Ashby just
quickly if you want to come back in this
isn't just a movement
I mean we are
asked being asked to take money out of
reserves our reserves are all ready very
low in comparison with other councils
and we are
um of the mind that we don't want to
actually erode any further are already
low reserves on uh making
something that is just a quick short fix
we we the whole budget is is based on a
future planning so we want to become
more self-sufficient if we get the
Estates team right and we do what we're
supposed to do and get our yield up from
a very low yield that we have at the
moment which is under three percent to
an acceptable level of about eight
percent we can afford 10 new street
cleaners every year next year the
following year in the following year but
if we don't if we don't invest in it now
then we will be missing this opportunity
so I'm afraid it is not just a paper
exercise this we do not as a as a
conservative Administration believe that
we should go raid our reserves just to
actually
um
make this uh what shall I say this is a
very highly contentious issue and and I
come back to councilor bayford's comment
whereby we should be looking at
um maybe restructuring our existing
resources to provide Extra cover on the
street cleaning but it is essential and
we will we we debated this long and hard
chair to actually look at how we can
actually grow the Estates and the
revenue that we own from our Estates is
vital to this Council and if we do not
support it that this department has been
neglected year on year on Year and that
is why we have that we're in the state
that we are at the moment so I'm afraid
chair again we cannot support this as an
Administration thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
the thing about castle Whitehead I know
you do want to come back in I mean we've
had questions education from counselor
uh Ashby on this so just briefly just
briefly 151 so to my understanding it's
not an either or situation we are not
swapping from funding from the states to
another area we are simply funding an
extra from reserves and I would like
Clarity on that from section one for
everyone please well look um just
briefly I'll call the 151 officer back
but I think after that we will move to
the vote
thank you chairman um I think the leader
has actually addressed the issue in the
fact that
um as you say Council Whitehead this is
a to to do both of these which would be
possible that's not a binary choice
between one or the other but to do both
you would need to be taking uh 85 000
pound out of the risk Reserve over the
next two years so that's 170 000 from it
so that's what members need to consider
there's one more clarification yes
councilor Everett did I ask the 151
officer just to give us a ballpark
figure for how much this budget takes
out of reserves overall
uh yes councilor Everett the 151 officer
will respond uh you'll note that there
are various different movements across
different Reserve items to hand
um
I'd need to just refer to the report to
get the net position
if you can bear with me
but there are a variety of different
reserves taken from there that are set
out within the report at section
my apologies
he's good you know but he does he is
going through all of this uh section
seven sets out our overall Reserve
levels well at the moment and then there
is uh further detail in the report
setting out all the different uh Reserve
movements that are contained within the
report
um sorry again just trying to refer to
the correct section
foreign
yeah if I could come back to you on that
apologies yeah he's good but it's out of
the blue councilor Everett and a little
difficult he will get back to you the
point I'm making is that there is a
substantial withdrawal from reserves in
this budget so the conservative position
that it's not a good idea to draw down
reserves particularly in support of
something which is revenue earning and
which we all agree is revenue owing is a
good idea isn't really an argument
against it thank you
right look um thank you councilor
Everett um we're going to move to the
vote now enough has been said we have
had clarification uh can I ask the
monitoring officer to in undertake a
recorded vote once again
okay thank you chair
again I'll start with the alphabetical
order
councilor Alvin you're right for okay
councilor Ashby
councilor Austin
[Music]
councilor Bailey
councilor bambridge
councilor Jill brayford
Council Robert bayford
and councilor Boyd she'll abstain
counselor batewood
waitwood
against
um councilor Coleman cook
counselor Crittenden
was that for
thank you Council Curry
councilor Dexter
[Music]
councilor Duckworth
councilor Everett
councilor fellows
Council Garner
counselor Hart against
councilor Hopkinson
[Music]
councilor Huxley
councilor Keane
councilor cup
Council Lays
counselor Pat Moore
councilor Paul Moore
counselor and and Marie Nixie
for
counselor ovenden
councilor Parson
councilinda Piper
and councilor Street Papa Europe Stein
thank you
counselor Pugh
I got you right this time
Castle Vatican
castle roof
Castle Rogers
sorry didn't hit that okay
and counselor uh
Okay so
I lost my country Council David Saunders
sorry
counselor Maeve Saunders
Council Savage okay cancer scoby
Scott
Castle chunk
counselor shop
cancer Smith
Castle Tomlinson
Castle towning
counselor falling
counselor Whitehead
Council of wing
Council right
events
Council Yates
just gives two minutes
she hasn't formally declared an interest
I know I know it's because Carrie is
because Carrie submitted online
right the result is
there's 24 the most for the Amendments
28 against and two abstention so the
motion is lost
thank you very much indeed Montreal so
that has fallen uh back to the
substantive agenda item therefore
councilor Duckworth
Third Amendment when labor proposed
climate emergency in 2019 we didn't do
it to win political points we did it to
follow the science and address the
climate submissions locally
I think I speak for everyone when I say
the tree planting officer we have is
excellent and it's been brilliant to
watch over a thousand trees planted
locally with schools Community groups
and residents invited to get their spade
out the important thing with the tree
planting is to get newly planted trees
watered for three years
following planting with our summers
getting hotter we need to ensure that
the trees we just planted stay alive
otherwise we've just spent time and
energy digging a hole only to put it in
again a few years later
labor therefore propose that we remove
000 pounds growth
for seaweed removal from the budget and
in view of the consensus that this item
is needed ask cabinet to consider a
different way to fund it at its March
meeting the 25 000 pounds saved to be
allocated to a new permanent role of
tree planting and biodiversity gain
officer
thank you very much new councilor
Duckworth I would point out again I know
I'm seeing pedantic but you end again on
a semicolon am I missing anything
do I have a seconder for this thank you
councilor effort uh who wants to speak
to this councilor Ash
lines about it being important to
Residents about street cleaning I
receive a lot more emails about seaweed
than I ever do about street cleaning
this is an ongoing issue this affects
not only our residents but it also
affects our tourism industry
dramatically
I've long campaigned for the clearance
of seaweed but it is a natural
phenomenon that happens many times many
years that I've been living in this
Coast
um so I'm afraid that we felt that it is
very important that we actually provide
funds for this and that the officers
have looked long and hard about how to
actually
maximize the efficiency of this clearing
so again chair I'm afraid I feel that
this is an unre reasonable proposal
coming from the budget I'm also somewhat
um
I was under the understanding
um that we actually had found a way of
funding the tree officer so it would be
unnecessary to actually withdraw this
25k
um but I would also remind officers um I
would also remind members that actually
councilor cup myself and Charlie Dench
my PA spent a week of our summer going
out with the council Bowsers watering
the trees so maybe they're you know
other contributions could be received
from Members I know that members do help
with the planting but a tree is for life
not just for the planting and the
photographers and the Press so
um chair I'm afraid I will not be
supporting this and obviously my members
can decide whether they are or not
thank you very much indeed councilor
Ashby councilor Everett
yes thank you chair and um I actually
agree with councilor Ashby that the
removal of seaweed is a priority for for
residents obviously in particular areas
of the district not across the district
but in particular areas it is a problem
and the council needs to do the job
properly but what we're proposing here
again is to uh the cabinet goes away and
finds another place to find that money
it's a relatively small sum of money in
this amendment it's 25 000 pounds when
you look at the revenue budget which I
think is 19.6 million and you look at
the council's revenue streams it's not
really that difficult to find twenty
thousand and I think what we should say
what is important and what is important
I think to all of our residents is the
natural environment and it is our
commitment to biodiversity gain and to
tree planting I think that's a common
cause across this Council and what I'd
like to say is it whilst it's true that
there may be another temporary stop Gap
way of funding a post
possibly if we'd had the previous
incumbent on a full-time contract they
wouldn't have gone off and got a job
somewhere else I can't speculate about
that it would be unreasonable to do so
but I think this Council needs to offer
its employees
um full-time positions permanent
positions so that they can stay here
build up experience build up knowledge
and deliver Workforce and hopefully
progress through this Council structure
I think this is an important Portman
statement that this Council would make
by spending a relatively small sum of
money to create a new post and make a
commitment to the natural environment
which I think we all share thank you
thank you councilor Everett is counselor
Pugh isn't it
yes no councilor public chair thank you
well done
um your hearing is certainly better than
you than your site at the moment so well
done
um I thank you councilor Duckworth for
your amendment that you've put forward
and I'd like to reiterate I think what
uh the leader has said you know
particularly about seaweed it is a
problem across our Coast
um and it is really important I don't
think that any budget should be removed
uh from that allocation but what I would
say is that particularly as this talks
about a permanent role for tree planting
and biodiversity gain officer you know
the labor group of Distributing
countless pages with I mean this one's
got not even five lines of text on it
um if we're talking about being a bit
more responsible I you know I don't know
this is the third amendment they've put
forward I don't know how many there are
but you know maybe they're all on the
same page double-sided we might might
save a few trees but I just just wanted
to put that out there thank you
[Applause]
thank you for that we've introduced some
Liberty uh I've got councilor Cup first
if that's all right leader
Jason
thank you chair
um I just wanted to say uh from a
counselor from birchington and I'm sure
many of the councilors that are
representing Coastal Wards see the
damage that happens many of the time
when the seaweed comes in the smell that
happens and I actually think this is
incredibly important and it is something
that I know a lot of residents will be
back in and it's something that
residents have asked us to do many a
time during the summer period and that
is why I think it's so important that's
in here and I would just say that these
are moments that are coming through
really does seem like that the labor
party are just getting desperate of what
amendments they can put in and they're
just trying to come up with anything
that doesn't really make any sense but
thank you sir
yes well even nevertheless uh councilor
Austin
thank you chair
I just wanted to ask a couple of
questions about this sorry because
um
I too like the leader thought there was
funding for the tree officer post and I
wasn't sure about the status that I'm
looking at corresponds we we too had
some suggestions about some Horticulture
posts and some enforcement posts which
we've been in discussion with the 151
officer about and decided not to bring
in an amendment on and with regard to
the Horticulture I understood that we do
have extension funding for the tree
planting post and that the difficulty As
I understood it from what the climate
change officer told us at the members
briefing on Monday was Finding locations
actually where we where we could be
doing the tree planting and that there
had to be a discussion about that with
Kent County Council before we could
progress I'm very keen to see every post
that we possibly can made permanent and
full time but I'm not quite clear about
where this sits also I understand from
corresponders with the 151 officer that
the biodiversity role which is still
vacant is funded in in the base budget
and I'd just like some confirmation of
that and how this is going to make a
difference to all of that thank you
thank you very much indeed
um I just since there's a point of
clarification I shall ask the leader
back
so I think councilor Duckworth had
her before me
were you there before I'm sorry about
that councilor Duckworth did you want to
come in you have already spoken by the
way
um so really
there's a point of order is it very
brief
uh yeah cancel Austin it's it's not so
much about tree planting is making sure
that the tree's already planted are
watered that's yeah so it's not it's not
about where we can plant trees so much
as the ones that are already there we
need to make sure that they don't
temporary
we want to make it permanent yes we're
not a backwards afford can I just remind
members that it is good practice to
stand when addressing the chamber I'm
not mentioning anybody in particular but
just as an over observation it's good
form councilor Ashby on a point of
clarification did you want to come back
in briefly
yeah
thank you chair
um I believe uh oh sorry
um I can just screen's gone
um
I could be corrected on this but um Anna
the excellent tree officer that we have
um I believe the role was funded out of
a fund that was the Queen's canopy fund
the Queens
um and it was known at that time
obviously that the tree the cost of the
trees the planting and the first year of
Maintenance was covered in this so we
actually knew it at that time
so I appreciate that it was a temporary
um post but that was all part of the bid
and I know quite a lot about tree bids
going back over the years but we won't
go into that
um
I understand
um I have been advised that we are still
funding the role
and we will seek further funding there
are funds coming out all the time from
the government initiatives and from the
forestry commission there are
probably about five or six different
schemes running at any one time that we
can actually apply for funding so I
actually think we're actually arguing
about something that we don't need to be
arguing about here because it is funded
Anna or if um Anna does leave the role
then there will be funding for an
officer to come in and cover this so and
I'm sure again that if we all put our
minds to it then we can seek the funding
that we need but I will remind
um uh all members that going back to
when we first started planting trees we
have to have in mind that these trees
need to be looked after for 60 70 80
years so you know we have to plan for
long after we've gone so
um we have to be mindful of bids when we
go in for them that we have to put in a
maintenance tail program in place
because this Council cannot be
responsible if we plant a million trees
in thanet this Council will not be able
to support a long-term maintenance plan
so we have to put that in place when
we've gone past the paparazzi and the
picture taking of tree planting thank
you chair but hopefully this now answers
the question and we can move on to the
vote thank you chair yes thank you very
in Dutch indeed leader I mean I I asked
the leader back in because it was an
important point of clarification
we also need to bear in mind it isn't
good form to mention officers by name
so in future let's not do that councilor
Garner I believe you indicated did you
no I thought you did my.gi again but at
least I gave you the chance right I
think we'll move to the vote
um once again a call upon the monitoring
officer
thank you chair
I'm just curious is this really an
amendment this is asking us to look at
something in a March meeting is it is
actually an amendment to this budget
I've accepted it as an amendment that's
not the question Jim
Sheriff I could be of assistance uh the
amendments were all drafted with the
support of our senior officers
so I mean it's a senior officer who
you're questioning
all right all right all right we've had
we've had a question of the
clarification and I'm also happy it was
an amendment we will move on to the vote
thank you councilman bayford
thank you chair
again it's the amendment number three
and in the alphabetical order councilor
album
counselor Ashby against
counselor Austin
councilor Bailey
councilor Banbridge
councilor Jill bayford
Council Robert bayford sorry Council
Boyd
casa batewood
okay
councilor common cook
cousin Crittenden
councilor Curry
Council Dexter
councilor Duckworth
[Music]
councilor Everett
councilor fellows
Council Gardner
Council of heart
s
councilor Hopkinson
councilor Huxley
counselor Keane
counselor cup
Council lace
counselor patmo
counselor Pomo
counselor Emery Nixie
counselor ovenden
councilor Parsons
councilinda Piper
councilor Stuart Piper
Christine
thank you
counselor Pugh
Council rating
Council Rose
Council Rogers
counselor russinski
Council David Saunders
councilor may may Saunders
Council Savage against
cancer scoby
cancer Scott
again sorry I didn't hear that again
against thank you Council chunk
Council shop
councilor Smith
councilor Tomlinson
Council towning
councilor rolling
councilor Whitehead
councilor wing
councilor Wright
and finally Council Yates
okay if you just give me two minutes to
count
councilor Everett did you want to come
in on something
of course yes
chair
yeah just a quick question it's all very
well labor handing out a few leaflets to
people so they can see the motion what
about the rest of us because we if we
can't see it why why should we even
debate it
well the way it works the work works is
that the uh proposal is made it is read
out it is discussed and debated and is
on that basis that we make a decision
however if any help I've been reliably
informed this is the last Amendment of
the evening
foreign
okay before you celebrate do you want to
hear the result for the third amendments
16 4 6 abstention and 28 against so it's
left
so that has fallen uh back to
substantive motion and counselor Everett
thank you chair
um I want to add my thanks to cabinet
members head officers for their work on
the budget and I I know it's a long and
arduous process
um I'm sorry that we weren't given the
opportunity to be more involved before
Christmas but that's water under the
bridge now
um and I'd like to thank in particular
Mr Blundell and others for their advice
on Labor's proposed amendments tonight
we are not opposing this budget
but we think it can be improved
and therefore I wish to move in a member
and this amendment would remove twenty
thousand pounds growth for seaweed
removal and in view of the consensus
that this item is needed ask cabinet to
find a different way to fund it at its
March meeting
and reallocate the 20 000 funding
to remove the plan decreasing charges at
the Royal Harbor car park in Ramsgate in
acknowledgment of the long-term lack of
working lifts and ongoing environmental
issues there
in terms of Revenue Royal Harbor car
park is a success story
I'm advised that in 2021-22 it generated
235 000 pound which was the highest of
any Council car park and yet for the
town it is an embarrassment and has been
for a number of years
under the labor Administration in 2021
000 was allocated from the
decriminalization fund to repair the
lifts but covid meant they could not be
used and therefore it wasn't done
in the summer of 2021 the present
Administration took over and the lifts
have been boarded up ever since
this is dangerous
it means pedestrians with limited
Mobility including parents with prams
have to use the vehicle ramps to change
floors which is a basic failing of
health and safety of which this Council
should be ashamed
these boarded up lifts do nothing to
enhance the lobby areas
the fire doors are in poor repair there
is pooling of water after it rains and
there are frequent problems with
cleanliness and antisocial Behavior
it is welcome that there is money in the
capital program for new fire doors and
concrete works and that the council has
made a three million pound provision to
buy the car park in 2025-26
I'm told that the money is still sitting
there in reserves to fix the lifts but
the long today delay would suggest that
it hasn't been a priority for this
Administration
I conclude that this car park in its
present state does not Merit a 10
increase it is deteriorated and it
offers worse facilities and the pricing
should reflect that
the 151 officer has shared his concerns
with us that changes to the proposed
charges could be deemed to imply that
they were not originally put forward
based on traffic management and as such
tracked the attention of the council's
auditor but it is for Council to set
these charges not cabinet and not with
respect the auditor or officers
this car park has plenty of spare
capacity on its upper floors at all
times it's really not credible that
freezing charges there will have a
material effect on traffic flow
financially the effects of a freeze on
the council's Revenue income is not
significant what freezing charges would
do is publicly acknowledge to the town
and the people that use Royal Harbor
that the state of this car park is
simply not good enough and that the
council recognizes that it must do
better
I moved the amendment
thank you very much near councilor
Everett once again I know it's a bit
pedantic you end on a semicolon is there
am I missing anything
no right okay have you got a seconder
councilor Alban who wishes to speak
no speed councilor Alban's going to
speak yet oh was it Council Austin sorry
Council are you with first you were
first right well I come back to you
Council Auburn councilor Austin
councilor Robin's arm is considerably
longer than mine I think
um uh as one of the ward councilors for
the ward in which uh the Royal Harbor
car park sits I am delighted at this
proposal and thoroughly support it the
Royal Harbor car park is a disgrace and
an embarrassment and a serious safety
problem we need to be doing something
about that as a matter of urgency but in
the meanwhile I support the idea that it
certainly does not warrant any increase
in charges thank you
thank you councilor Austin councilor
Auburn did you want to come in uh yeah
just very briefly Cherry in in that uh I
think the two speakers so far have put
it very succinctly it is an absolute
disgrace year and something needs needs
to be done I know it's difficult that
we're coming up to a gap in the uh in
the lease on it because it doesn't own
it it leases it and uh as as was said
earlier you know uh when I was a Cabinet
member that we got this 300 not thousand
pound to be put into repair the lifts uh
and also knowing that there's concrete
well what's down is concrete cancer and
part of it and that does need to be
dealt with and also uh my understanding
is and I may be uh
put put right on this but it it is a
repairing leash here so if the council
decided not to uh
uh continue with the lease we'd have to
we'd have to put it back into the state
as when we got it and it's certainly not
in a state as when we got it chair so I
would hope that members would support
this amendment thank you very much
thanks to the councilor Auburn
is anybody going to reply to that
councilor Ashby thank you chair I can
remember a while back looking at the
same issue with this
um I'm surprised that uh Council Everett
thinks it's a success story I actually
disagree with that I don't believe this
car park has ever made any money
and I would suggest that if we were to
take it back under the ownership of
thanet District Council and by raising
sufficient parking fees for it then
money could be invested back into it and
it could be a revenue generated for the
council overall so um 20 000 pounds if
the car park is a state that everyone
says it's in twenty thousand pounds he's
not even going to pay for a deep clean
so I think we're just
um attacking the seaweed removal
um because is it because a lot of the
conservative Wards are actually Coastal
based but the labor rules aren't I don't
know I wouldn't like to suggest that but
I would say that this needs to come
under the parking review plan which will
will be judged across the whole parking
facilities within thanit both on street
and off Street and hopefully a correct
and in-depth review of our parking will
result in a balanced parking fee across
the island and where we can actually
examine hopefully with the leveling up
money and all the good things that are
happening around skate will bring lots
of revenue from visitors coming into the
car park that can be actually upgraded
when it is started to earn its living I
think that is the way forward for this
Council we can't just keep throwing
money at things we have to make the
assets earn their living earn their keep
and then we can invest reinvest back
into our Estates thank you chair
yes thank you um I'll just like to
remind the leader uh on this point point
of all of that Ramsgate is actually
located on the sea chair thank you very
much
oh well that's good that's good
counselor Saunders moving swiftly on
councilor Saunders I'll be very Swift uh
chairman
um
I support
um or I could support
the proposal that we
um that we'd only increase the fees and
charges within that particular car park
um
but the amendment is in my opinion is
wrongly worldly because I cannot support
taking more money out of the seaweed
removal growth plan
um I agree that that car park is an
architectural desire a disaster whoever
designed the lower level with the
underpass walkway to Wilkos these
absolutely shooting the lifts I know it
was a good idea at the time but in these
better lighting and it's always like
been the same I can remember it when it
was first opened what 50 years ago and
it's always been an area that shall we
say needs addressing with regards to
lighting Etc so although I would support
a proposal within the parking strategy
that those fees are are
maintained at their current level what I
can't do is support this amendment the
way it's worded because I will not
support the the twenty thousand pound
removal from the seaweed removal
provision that we have in the budget
thank you
thank you councilor Saunders but just in
support of the architectural profession
it's possible the car park was not
designed by an architect councilor Wing
yes
it sounds like on the coast obviously in
regular sea Dipper on both the west and
Undercliff
main sons and we do we do in fact have
seaweed
counselor thank you very much councilor
Keane
thank you very much I think we're
missing a really important Point here
the problem with the car park is that it
is a health and safety issue it's an
immediate issue that needs resolving it
disadvantages disabled people people
with young families and that is why this
is such an important amendment that I
really hope people will support because
otherwise we are leaving part of our
population ill-served thank you
thank you very much councilor Keem
councilor Huxley
thanks chair so he's a disgraceful part
is the leader happy with that has she
actually been there recently
um it's if we got 300 000 pounds in the
reserves that councilor
album actually put aside for it two
years ago why haven't we done the lifts
you know I've had people come up to me
when I had Parts in the car park with a
wheelchair user they've driven up to the
second floor and they can't get down the
stairs or you know they take their life
and their hands going down to the next
level it's not good enough why aren't
those lifts working now why haven't they
been replaced
um is the leader happy with that she
should come with us and and uh the
central Harbor cancers and have a look
at it because it's dirty it's it's
disgusting it needs a repaint for start
what does she think about that thank you
thank you councilor Huxley and the
leader has already spoken on this so and
this is clarification which no it is is
it yeah I was named and asked the
question so I'd appreciate the right to
respond well I'm sure it'll be a
clarification as well won't it actually
yes I do visit the car park quite often
and every time I go to Ramsgate which is
quite frequently at least once a
fortnight if not once a week I do Park
in the car park and I will yes it is a a
car park that is very typical of car
Parks across the country that is that
are actually in bad state but yes there
was a deep clean I believe I did walk
around with the wall councilors at the
time when we were discussing the safety
issues of going across to the to the
Wilco through the underpass there I
agree with you it is a disgusting car
park but
I failed to see how the 20 000 is going
to help things what we need is a
sustainable future for that car park and
I feel that if we actually build this
right within the car park strategy that
we're just tinkering with the edges
doing this so yes I do Park in there I
do come to Ramsgate quite often actually
um you will find me around around in
Ramsgate in fact I'll probably go to
Ramsgate more than I do my own walls um
but uh apart from living there and
walking there but uh no I I you know I
the point is is that we need to try and
make a sustainable future for for our
assets and and this is why we've got to
look at this just taking 20 pounds out
of the seaweed removal is not going to
assist this twenty thousand thank you
thank you very much for that
clarification councilor Ashby what I
would I should call upon Council
Whitehead now but I think the issue has
been dealt with adequately so if I can
call on the last speaker as councilor
Whitehead
thank you chair
um I would oddly enough like to speak in
support of the leaders mention of the
sustainable future it was early I've
argued that
the income from the car park is
necessary in order to sustain the future
of the car park
but at thinking in terms of how tourism
works here
the state of the car park currently is
not going to invite people to return
again I think it's more likely to damage
our reputation as a tourist area so in
relation to the sustainable future of
Tourism here I think it is something
that has to be acted upon thank you
thank you very much Casper Whitehead can
we move to the vote now please
monitoring officer
is it a point of order councilor Huxley
well I don't know just I really didn't
answer my question about the lifts if
there's something no it has to be a
point of order because you've already
spoken but that's unfortunately she
hasn't actually answered the lifts so
there's money for the lifts and they
haven't been replaced why not we're
moving to the vote now thank you very
much
thank you chair
extension Council album
Council Ashby
against
counselor Austin
counselor Bailey
councilor Banbridge
councilor Jill bayford
Council Robert bayford
councilor boy yeah thank you councilor
batewood
counselor Coleman cook against counselor
Crittenden
Castle Curry
cancer Dexter things
councilor Everett
Caster fellows
Council Ghana
councilor Hart against
councilor Hopkinson
councilor Huxley
councilor Keane
counselor cup
counselor lace
counselor patmore
counselor Pomo things
counselor Emery Nixie
councilor oven
councilor Parson
Castle Indy Piper
and Casa Stewart you will remain
outstage counselor Potts
no no sorry
Castle pew
ter right again
Council Rife
Castle Rogers
um
foreign
ers
Pastor Savage
counselor scoby
[Music]
Casa Scott
Casper Smith
Castle Tomlinson
Council towning
Castle Bowling
that's the right head
counselor wing
Castle right
counselor Yates
just give me two minutes
okay the vote is 19 in favor two abstain
and 29 against so it's lost
thank you very much that has fallen
we're back to the substantive motion
again uh any speakers
question you know Captain White who is
in first
councilor often I take a I take
alphabetical order councilor Austin
thank you chair
um
we would like to thank uh the 151
officer and his team for all their help
and information
um during the process of discussing this
we came up with a series of of ideas
some of which interestingly uh mirrored
some of what the labor group has put
forward and in the end decided not to
bring any proposals to to this meeting
but we are broadly very supportive of
the budget uh supportive of the
priorities that have been identified
however
uh the areas that we are uncertain about
and very worried about is the area of
borrowing and capital spend on Ramsgate
Port because we don't feel that we have
as Ward cancers sufficient information
to support that we have asked repeatedly
for more information the finance team
have been very helpful in sending us
some project initiation documents for
some of the capital uh projects but they
were sketchy to say the least
um and uh the leader has just said we
can't keep throwing money at things and
I'm afraid we feel that there's a bit of
that with with this uh councilor Wing
I'm sure we'll follow this up in more
detail but we are very concerned about
that aspect of the budget and as such I
think the Ramsgate green councils will
probably be abstaining because we don't
feel that we can support that part in
its present form thank you
thank you very much Council Wing I'm
just going to Echo what councilor Austin
said basically uh I mean we've we've
repeatedly asked over a number of years
and if you look at parts of the budget
the housing bit for example is so well
evidenced every spend right down to a
window is there well evidenced well
supported by documentation in terms of
need future liabilities are there and
what we really worry about with the port
is is are we doing what we should be
doing is it is it based in evidence of
need and also what really worries me
about future liabilities so we already
know the cement better prevents presents
us with with very much a significant
cost to Residents because of that
original lease agreement and what we
don't want is we don't we we need to
know that the future that that there are
that everything that happens on that
Port is well evidence there is a
business case and that we've looked at
the worst and best case scenario of any
future risk to Residence and tax payers
so like Council Austin I've I've
overwhelmingly support the budget but
that bit just doesn't sit well with us
in terms of the evidence and the
paperwork so I will be abstaining as
well
thank you councilor Whitehead
thank you chair
firstly I would like to thank everyone
involved in the preparation of the
budget especially the 151 officer in his
team and I'm fully aware of the level of
effort involved
as a matter of personal interest I fully
welcome the usage of the new homes bonus
towards further in-house homelessness
accommodation
as many know it is exactly how I would
have used it
roughly a year ago I said these words in
this chamber
the conservative budget proposes to use
the 549 000 new homes bonus to pay off
debt the labor group proposes to amend
this budget allocation we propose to set
aside the remainder of the new homes
bonus to fund the provision of
additional in-house temporary
accommodation
I Then followed this appraisal with the
following argument
property values in Margate alone Rose by
14.4 percent last year they are
predicted to rise again to that level
over the coming year delaying purchases
by one year increases the cost of
purchase by an estimated 15 according to
predictions
which means that delaying the purchase
of property now costs us an additional
82 350 pounds to buy equivalent property
in a year's time
there is no debt that we could pay down
there or that is accruing interest at
that level
the argument is not sound and is the
opposite of fiscal responsibility
politics does not have to be
oppositional we are at our weakest when
it becomes so because it blinds us to
the potential in ideas and to the good
in others which feels particularly
pertinent at the moment
I put forward that argument cabinet
overview and scrutiny and Council and my
idea was still rejected in spite of it
being fiscally sound
since I made that argument property
inflation in Margate has increased by a
further 10 to 24.5 and inflation has
increased to 11 and overall likely
increase in purchase and development
costs of 25.5 in the last year alone
I fought for months to push for the
usage of last year's new homes bonus for
further in-house temporary accommodation
because I knew that we would be facing
extraordinary pressures in the coming
year and with an 800 000 pound growth in
paying for private temporary
accommodation I believe I was more than
right to do so
So reading this budget is Bittersweet I
welcome wholeheartedly the usage of this
year's new homes bonus towards further
in-house temporary accommodation and
will support cabinet in that in whatever
way I can because I believed it was
necessary then and I believe it is
necessary now
but having had that idea turned down
over and over and again to see now see
it brought forward in this year's budget
with the previous year's new homes bonus
used to pay off a lot far lower debt it
is painful to see and acknowledge that
the buying power that we had last year
is now reduced by almost 26 percent
the potential loss of buying power I
predicted last year if we didn't use the
new homes bonus then was 82 350 pounds
that loss will likely now be far closer
to 139 995 pounds due to inflation and
further property increases and we are a
year behind where we could be in terms
of creating the in-house temporary
accommodation we desperately need to and
I would be lying if I said I didn't feel
that keenly
this is the history of this proposal but
it has a very very bright future and I
welcome it fully thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
Whitehead uh it's not yours
councilor Jill bayford
thank you chair
um I I do feel that councilor
Whitehead's proposal last year was
totally different uh we were looking at
uh using the sum of money available to
purchase properties at that time and and
we I think we're all aware that it would
only have financed the maximum of two
two units
we prefer this this we are looking not
only at helping people now but also in
the future and we believed in a strategy
where the the new homes bonus is added
to other sums to fund
a number of units at many units in the
future so I feel that the proposal of
last year and this one are totally
different thank you
thank you and any more
who have we got Castle Ashby did you
want to come in just briefly chair
I thought I was gonna have an easy night
tonight but obviously not um
I would just like to reiterate
um thanks to
Chris Blundell 151 officer and the team
but also the officers all the officers
that were involved with the Star Chamber
it wasn't just the financial thing all
the directors and department heads came
to give their cases and it was actually
very very worthwhile exercise and we
learned actually a lot about the
different elements and the Crossovers
between Department Etc but I'd also like
to give thanks to the cabinet because
um obviously it was a quite an arduous
task for us and I actually think that
this Administration put together a
pretty good budget
um and um and it's not that I just would
say that anyway wouldn't I but
um we've tried to be Progressive and
we've tried to be
generous in whoever takes control of
this Council in May
to build the foundations for taking it
Forward I think I feel we've come a long
way I think the budget sends out the
signal that we are on on the way up
um as a council overall so but
especially I'd like to mention David
Saunders who um has obviously born the
brunt of this whole budget and he's done
a superb job throughout this this uh
budget process so I'd also like to thank
councilor David Saunders for all his
work putting this together thank you
and I think we all agreed on that aren't
we
thank you very much indeed should we
move to the vote now I turn to the
monetary officer what's this
thank you chair
again in alphabetical order four against
her upstairs
Council open I know councilor Ashby for
councilor Austin
councilor Bailey for counselor Ben
Bridge
councilor bayford Jill bayford
Council Robert bayford
councilor Boyd abstain
counselor Brightwood
councilor Coleman cook for counselor
Crittenden
Castle Curry
cancer Dexter
councilor Duckworth
councilor Everett
counselor fellows
councilor Gregory
no this is the other one Castle gardener
Castle heart Castle Hopkinson
counselor Huxley Castle King
Tesla cup
castler lace
Tesla pack more
counselor Pomo
counselor Emery Nixie
counselor ovenden
Tesla Parson
Castle Linda Piper
and counselor
upstairs
okay counselor Pugh
Council Vatican
cancel both
because
again
Castle Rogers
counselor rosinski
[Music]
Casa Davis
Saunders
Casa Savage for Casa scoby Casa Scott
Castle shrub
counselor Smith
for cancer Tomlinson
Casa towning counselor falling
castle of Whitehead
councilor wing
counselor Wright
and finally councilor Yates
two minutes and now count
right the result is 44 members four five
abstain and one against
but it's great thank you very much after
considerable deliberation we have a
gender item seven behind us therefore
moving on to gender item eight the
budget monitoring for 2022 2023 the
report number one again I call upon
counter David Saunders
thank you chairman and thank you members
for uh your support uh with regards to
the budget but I haven't finished yet
so budget monitoring report number one
this report presents a number of Revenue
and capital budget adjustments that were
considered by cabinet and its meeting on
the 13th of October 2022 and our
substance and subsequently recommended
to council for approval sorry
members should note the budget
adjustments relate to one-off
expenditure items for 22 23 and as such
they do not affect the 23 24 budget that
we have just presented and thankfully
approved
chairman I move the recommendations
within the report budget monitor report
number one thank you
thank you very much councilor Saunders
Do you have a seconder councilor Ashby
do members agree
thank you very much
gender item 9 the budget monitoring
report quarter to 2022 2023
again I called upon Council Saunders
thank you chairman
this report also presents an in-year
budget adjustment for Council approval
as recommended by cabinet following
consideration of the mid-year 2223
budget monitoring report that was
received by cabinet on the 15th of
December
2022. the adjustment facilitates the
appointment of interim property
surveyors with a focus on generating
additional property income for the
council
I moved the recommendations chairman
thank you councilor Saunders do you have
a seconder councilor Ashby
members do you agree
thank you very much
the last item on the agenda agenda item
10 changes to committees panels and
boards with members please note that the
agenda item 10 changes to these
committees will be deferred to the next
council meeting on Thursday the 23rd of
February uh